what Bob asked me to do I guess that's
what's happening in this series it's a
different kind of talk than I'm used to
giving which is just tell you about for
decades and bioethics a lot of you here
haven't had for decades anyplace there's
a few of you who may have had that many
so let me do that feel free to jump in
with questions or comments or whatever
at any point I was an undergraduate at
Cornell and Ruth Macklin who you also
had she and I were classmates there
although we didn't know each other at
the time I got out of there in 59 and
here's a piece of my career that you
probably don't know I then spent four
years in investment banking at one of
the leading Wall Street firms at the
same time I did all the coursework for
an MBA and then decided I wanted to do
something more worthwhile in my life
than that and so I came up here to
Columbia to the philosophy department
and did a PhD finished that in 1969 and
a PhD in ethics and political philosophy
nobody studied bioethics then there was
no place to study it and the term
bioethics wasn't in fact coined until
1971 or 72 so if you'd you know if your
spell check would have rejected it as
not a legitimate term so I 1969 I went
to Brown University as an assistant
professor and teaching ethics and
political philosophy which is what I had
done in my work here and Brown at that
time had what probably most of you never
heard of a two-year medical school a
two-year medical school was one where
they the students came and did the first
two years of medical school which or any
of you medical students and you
Proctor's soon to be okay well in any of
it the first two years of medical school
are typically classroom kind of work and
in and the underlying basic sciences and
that's what Brown had at that time and
then the funding changed and there were
no more two-year medical schools you
either had to fish or cut bait and the
sense of move to a four-year school or
go out of business and the faculty at
Brown was terrified that go that going
to a four-year medical school would
bankrupt the whole university turned out
they were quite wrong in the 70s the
medical school was the most solvent part
of the university but so they went to a
four-year medical school and so in the
in the early 70s the first Dean of the
Medical School came over to the
philosophy department to try to interest
a couple of us and not exactly sure what
but try to interest us in biomedicine
and in working with them John Ladd was a
more senior member of my department
working in ethics he and I hooked up
some we started doing some under gret
the first course I taught in bioethics I
taught with a guy named Sidney Cobb who
was a psychiatrist and his father was
Stanley cough that means that I think do
you but and he and I taught a course
together for undergraduates on ethics in
the field of mental health and the first
paper I wrote in bioethics is what you
have to do to get started was on
involuntary commitment of the mentally
ill it was paper I wrote for a
conference I think down in Texas as I
recall and so
people of my vintage our careers are
serendipity really at least if we're in
bioethics nobody was trained in
bioethics of my of my generation and
nobody got out of graduate school no
matter what they were trained in
thinking that they would go into that
field I certainly didn't so the way
serendipity went for me I I we started
some undergraduate courses it turned out
there was a lot of interest among
undergraduates we actually developed the
first undergraduate major in the country
in bioethics in the late 70s actually we
had an active group of undergraduates
they put on a couple of conferences
themselves it's always good you can get
the students to put on conferences the
so I wrote a couple more pieces I was
teaching a bit and then in as Bob
mentioned but he didn't put the dates
around it and 1980-81
I think it was the offer of this job was
kind of interesting the day after the
morning after Reagan was elected for the
first time I got a call from someone who
is now probably my best friend but at
that point I didn't know him well at all
we'd been together at a conference on
paternalism and met there and that was
it
dan wiggler who you've also probably
heard of and liquor called and said I
had already been down at the Commission
but he called and said how would you
like to be the staff philosopher next a
philosopher for the bioethics Commission
well I said there probably won't be one
didn't seem like Reagan was very
interested in that but in any event it
turned out there there was the bioethics
at that point was saved by the fact that
it was very low profile so it took
Reagan quite a while to get around to
appointing his own his own commissioner
and so for most of the time of the
commission Jimmy Carter's appointees
were in a majority the so I went down my
my wife my two kids and I moved down to
Washington for the year if you have a
chance to do things like this do it it
was extremely interesting I learned a
lot doing it we put out about ten
reports on different topics
some of them we'd been assigned to do by
the President and others we just took on
ourselves the first thing that that
Commission did was a report on defining
death when we held hearings on that and
so forth it was quite clear that people
were much more interested in issues
around stopping life-sustaining
treatment than they were in the
definition of death some people were
were and we got a uniform definition of
death developed so we did on our own a
report on
I think it's called deciding to forego
life-sustaining treatment that was the
most I think influential report we did
because it was nicely timed this was a
period when it was four years after
Quinlin it was a time in which people
didn't didn't feel confident about what
it was okay to do and I even a year or
two later after this I would get asked
all the time about whether it was okay
to stop life-sustaining treatment for
example or once a week I would have
somebody tell me that it wasn't legal to
do so now that wasn't true then but the
fact is that there was just no consensus
about what it was okay to do well that's
a great time to be writing a report
right because you can have a lot of
influence when I got back to Rhode
Island Hospital which is where I'd been
working some
first meeting I went into was a case
consultation and the hospital risk
manager that's typically a lawyer whose
dessert whose job it is to keep hospital
at the hospital out of trouble
he basically walked into the room he was
carrying our report on deciding to
forego Isis aiding treatment he said
well the President's Commission says
it's okay so it's okay now that's not a
very good philosophical argument that
it's not one at all but but nevertheless
yeah you know it allowed some of the
things we did to be very influential
because they were coming into a period
when most of the court cases you have
heard about hadn't yet come come to
court and people were uncertain about
what was okay to do so it's an
interesting time we as I said we did
reports on informed consent on research
risks on genetic therapy or genetic
modification on life-sustaining
treatment on definition of death I've
probably forgotten some of them and
another access to health care it was
called securing access to health care
and one of the most important things we
did was at that point nobody knew how
many people didn't have health care and
so we had an a health economist on the
staff and she set to work to get the
data on this and we came up with 22 to
25 million people without health
insurance at that point when we
published that everybody said that can't
be right you must have forgotten to
count Medicare or you must have
forgotten pick out Medicaid but it was
right and I needless to say you know
it's still way above that but
nevertheless it put the problem on the
map to some extent that was the only
report we had a dissent from one of the
commissioners about because he was
basically a conservative libertarian and
didn't think it was the government's job
to to get health care and health care or
health care insurance to people the way
the Commission
with structures there were commissioners
who were political appointees and then
there was a staff of about a dozen now
Alex Caron was the chair of the the
executive director and then there was a
couple lawyers health economist health
sociologist philosopher when I got there
I was told you got to have cards printed
up because in Washington everybody has a
business card so philosophers certain
academics in general didn't have them in
those days and certainly philosophers
didn't so I went with the model that we
used for these and it you know had the
presidential seal on it it was very
fancy looking and it had the name of the
commission which was a very you you
actually didn't do the complete name of
the Commission but it was very long and
then underneath it had my name and staff
philosopher the guy who printed them up
thought it was a joke card as opposed
when he gave them to me but so that was
a very satisfying experience as I say I
learned a lot and the other one other
feature of it for a lot of academics
they're not used to join to doing
collaborative work in medicine of course
the collaborative work is almost always
the norm you know you see articles with
40 authors listed and philosophy that
wasn't the norm at all most of my
colleagues at Brown had never
co-authored with another colleague but
here everything we did was jointly done
none of it came under our own names but
different of us would do different parts
and I found I enjoyed that kind of
collaborative work and I've actually
done collaborative work with some of the
people who are on the staff at that time
so if you have a chance to do something
like that
take it it's it simply is very gratified
one of the things I've always liked
about bioethics you know as I mentioned
to you I went to
graduated school wanting to do something
that felt to me more worthwhile than
Investment Banking it was the time at
that point that was time the civil
rights movement the Vietnam War etc and
being able to do something more than
just teaching it in the classroom has
been a way of satisfying that desire at
least for me we were actually
influencing practice in ways that we
thought were good for patients and
people and that was that was gratifying
so I left came back to Providence which
is where I was living then had a grant
from the Rhode Island Commission for the
Humanities and the other half of which
was paid by the Medical School and about
1983 to be a philosopher and residents
at Rhode Island College Road Island
Hospital it was a pretty nice grant
because there was no product that I was
supposed to come up with all I was to do
was to hang around wherever it seemed
interesting in the hospital and this is
also something you should take guess
offer to you of it you don't need me to
tell you that go wherever it seemed
interesting that included things like
the ICU the ER and so forth and I had
there were two residents there at the
time some of you may know the names Bob
Arnold and Lachlan Faro were both
residents there in the best residency
program that brown had at that time
honored Phyllis it was an in general
internal medicine and they had gone to
the head of their residency program and
said they wanted to have some ethics
teaching in it the head of it was Steve
Wortman who's now I think at the double
AMC or something and he said fine find
somebody to teach it so they looked
around and they came across from the
medical school to the undergraduate
campus and found me
and that was the first teaching you know
medical context that I did it was
teaching residents which is very good
time to teach because residents have now
have responsibility for patients but in
any event and these were these were
smart people but when I had this grant
to be phosphorus then they sort of paved
my way
I remember going with one of the things
I decided I should definitely do is to
stay up all night so people wouldn't
tell me yeah you know it's like to stay
up all night and make decisions so I did
and went around with Laughlin and we
went into one patient excuse me and
Lachlan introduced me as a as a I don't
know whether he said philosopher or
professor from Brown and the patient
said well what are you going to do for
me straighten out your arguments I don't
know but what that experience did was to
give me at least some experience within
flavor of a clinical setting obviously
the experience in Washington didn't have
that at all
and my normal work for the philosophy
department obviously didn't have that at
all and I think it's important to at
that point especially at that point in
time especially you had to earn your
credibility with with medical people
they weren't too interested unless you
show them where they should be and
listening to non physicians at that
point was not common to have have people
like me or frankly anyone identified as
a bioethicists teaching in medical
schools at that time Brown just started
some shortly after that but they were
fairly early when I went to Harvard and
2004 there there was no require there
were no required courses for medical
students that's 20 years later which is
somewhat of a disgrace I thought but in
any event I'll come back to that but so
I started working for the I started
working for the medical school and was
in charge of teaching for medical
students and we did that teaching in the
mostly in the third year in the
clerkships which was very nice because
that was the point in time in which the
medical students were out of the
classroom and were actually being
exposed to patients and so we often
taught off actual patients that the
medical students had been seeing and
they usually did the teaching combining
the medical students with the particular
residency team that they were attached
to at the time which gave a little more
experience to the group and it worked
quite well in teaching in medical
schools you take what time they'll give
you it's hard to get time time is
probably more important than more scarce
than parking places and that that scarce
right if you ever take an academic job
make sure you negotiate a parking place
I was in a meeting with the with the
Provost number two person at Harvard
about a week a couple of weeks ago and I
said I parked with someone else who was
there and he and he said you mean you
have assigned to parking as if he didn't
which I do actually but so I taught for
about a quarter time and for the rest of
the eighties in the medical school and
then I I was trying to remember exactly
how this happened but in any event there
was a there was a job at Hopkins
running a new bioethics program the
program that Ruth was her lesson yeah
right
runs now but it hadn't started and it
was in it was going to be in the medical
school and somehow I ended up
interviewing that for that I can't
actually remember what led to it all but
and God offered the job and and at that
time decided I didn't want to be
full-time in a medical school which was
what I would have been at Hopkins to is
probably don't know the medical school
and the undergraduate and graduate
campus are quite a ways to apart from
each other it's a 20 minute draw excuse
me it's a 20 minute drive from one to
the other so what the philosophy
department would have been happy to have
me I realized that I wouldn't have any
time to be there but that did I at that
point I I went to halftime with the
medical school and halftime still with
the philosophy department and you want a
tenth attend to I never I didn't try to
interview for another job until about 12
years after that but if you find you're
making too little money getting outside
offers is one way to increase them
increase it so there's another thing you
should learn if you don't already know
it that's when you have some bargaining
some bargaining position so then in 1993
after just after Clinton was elected he
started his health reform effort and
this was eat in many ways even more
interesting than the work on
President's Commission it was a huge
operation there were about 500 people
involved in the putting together their
proposal so-called it used to be called
Hilary's but it was it was as much his
as Hilary's and it was as much IRA
Magaziner says either of them but and
the group was was broken down into
different working groups and by this
time ethics was more on the map they had
an ethics working group fifteen years
before that nobody would have ever
thought of doing anything like that and
you guys will all benefit from the fact
that bioethics has earned a place in
efforts like this that twenty years ago
it didn't have and thirty years ago it
certainly didn't in any case they had an
ethics working group and I was asked to
be on that there were about twenty
twenty four people on it all it had to
be diverse in any in every respect that
you can think of training people had
ethnic groups racial groups gender etc
it was quite diverse it was interesting
because bioethics up till then was
pretty much focused on clinical issues
form consent life-sustaining treatment
surrogate decision-making and most of
the people that were picked for this
ethics working group frankly weren't
terribly qualified to do it because they
had been working on these clinical
issues and that was wasn't what this
effort was about this effort was trying
to think about restructuring the
healthcare system so there were some
people Zeke Emanuel was on that group he
certainly was up to speed on these
things norm Daniels was on the on that
group I was on it but there but a lot of
the people had only worked on clinical
issues and not on sort of structure of
the healthcare system and I hardly
commend to you knowing enough that the
structure of the healthcare system that
you can tackle these issues you should
take some economics if you haven't done
it for example so that was I I was
already committed to teaching summit
breath so I went back and forth every
week spent three days in Washington and
then came back back to Brown and taught
for two days then came back went back to
Washington that was quite a fascinating
effort and it was about as educational
as anything I've ever done because there
were all these other working groups
working on the other parts of doing this
the only task that that the ethics
working group was assigned it was to
develop the principle the ethical
principles which underlie the health the
new health plan and about halfway
through our work at one of our meetings
I noted that we hadn't done that yet
haven't even started it so Nancy dubler
I don't know whether you've had her here
but she was what the one of the two
co-chairs she said well why don't you
ignore him norm Daniels work on those
tonight so we Norman I call these the
polo principals because he went to a
restaurant called the Polo Club on
Connecticut Avenue that fortunately
didn't have a liquor license so her so
something fairly coherent came out of it
and we put together the principles that
couldn't actually use and again a kind
of experience that I commend to you if
you have the opportunity for it you I
learned an enormous amount that I didn't
know by by that so but I went back to
brown after that I never really left
entirely and in 2000 2000 2001 I guess
it was I had a
there was a department of clinical
bioethics at NIH that Zeke Emanuel
headed and they had a visiting scholar
each year and Zeke invited me to be the
visiting scholar it's basically like a
sabbatical for the whole year you know
that counts as a no-brainer to me so I
took it we again my wife and children
moved down to move down to Bethesda NIH
is in Bethesda Maryland and my very
first morning you know when I went to
the office there was September 11
I'm sorry November whatever it was 9/11
so I got there and everybody was around
the television looking at what was going
on but so I I liked the time there
because I had my Brown was a wonderful
place if he got offered a job there
taken it I liked my time there I liked
my job there I had basically everything
I would want but I didn't have a lot of
colleagues who were doing serious
scholarship in bioethics that's what I
had when I was at NIH in spades there
are about nine faculty they had a
postdoc program plus a post
baccalaureate program for students just
getting out of just getting finishing
college we've had several from Columbia
actually and so it was and we didn't
have any teaching responsibilities
you're basically there to do your own
research as he cast me if I wanted to be
on an ethics committee I said no thanks
and that was fine I had been on wanted
Brown for 15 years and shared it for
half that time
then in the spring you'll see why I
remember this he asked me to come into
his office and he said I want to hire
you I think I could give you anything
you want which was a very sick start
good start to negotiations there was one
thing that I'll tell you in a minute
that he didn't know he could couldn't
give me and I didn't know he couldn't
either but so I thought about it and I
decided to stay there intending to
finish out my career there and so we
sold our house in Providence and bought
a house in Washington and expected to
stick around and we liked Washington's
good city lots of great museums a lot
better restaurants than there were the
first time I was in Washington and it
was a very collegial pleasant and
productive working environment what led
so why did I leave well I left because I
ran into censorship from NIH I had we
every article that comes out of the
National Institutes of Health has to be
screened and there's typically screened
by the particular Institute in question
so say at the National Cancer Institute
they get screened by some committee
within the NCI and likewise they didn't
quite know what to do with ethics they
thought well maybe its policy and then
we have to really look at it but so we
submitted our stuff to we were located
in the hospital center and we sent it in
for clearance in the head of the
Hospital Center and then it went into
the senior one of the senior people in
NIH and it had always been a pro forma
thing we used to send it in for
clearance at the same time we sent it in
for publication because we'd never had
an issue
until I came along and I Tim quill who
was one of the plaintiffs in one of the
two assisted suicide cases in fact the
one from New York that went to the
Supreme Court
it's called quill V vuco vuco was the
District Attorney than I think but Tim
quill and I had written a paper thinking
Gemma or a New England Journal forget
which on end of life options probably
eight or nine years before this and he
just asked me if I would bring it up to
date because he wanted to put it in a
volume he was editing and I said sure
didn't seem like a big deal to me a lot
of work which I did and then so I sent
it back to Tim when I was finished and I
sent it in for clearance and about a
little less than a week later I got a
call from my goddess Minh who's in
charge of all intramural research at NIH
that's all the research that takes place
in the Institute's not the stuff they
fund here and elsewhere and he said hold
up submitting it I want to I need to
talk with somebody else and some other
people in building one so who do you
think's in building one right there who
knee and other people like that the
senior administration of NIH and dragged
on dragged on I kept after after him and
then about probably six weeks finally he
got back to me and he said okay I've
talked with a lot of skirble who is the
associate director for public policy and
Raynard Kington who was the number two
person at the NIH then and we we want
you to make some changes here the
changes we want you to make so the first
was they wanted me to change the title
no big deal they didn't want physician
assisted suicide in the title this was
the time at which Ashcroft was suing
state of Oregon
under the drug treatment laws and then
the second thing they said we want to
change the conclusion which was a bit
more
a bit more of an issue and he said you
know with the I think your arguments are
terrific as if they had no relationship
for the conclusion but so I wasn't about
to do that and it became a big deal went
up d'azyr who knew who was the head of
NIH then and it wasn't getting solved
and so some friends at Harvard you know
them who were on the search committee
for a position there that I said I
wasn't interested in because that point
I thought I would stay in well in
Washington said we'd like to reconsider
they knew all the crap I was going
through NIH at that time would you like
to reconsider and I said you know I
think maybe would and then there was a
an opening at a new chair in bioethics
at the Hopkins School of Public Health
and I ended up getting well I was going
back I ended up getting offered both
them in any event and ended up at
Harvard in part because it was going to
be a and actually I've I accepted the
Hopkins job on a Thursday both of them
were you know active jobs and then
Dennis Thompson who runs some programs
at Harvard called me on a Sunday and
said try to get me to accept the Harvard
job I said well you're too late I
already turned it down I accepted
Hopkins and he said oh you'd be great to
head the ethics in health program I said
what ethics in health program hadn't
been even mentioned in the search
because it there was just a memo
proposing it from three faculty and I
said well if I was so he said well why
don't you reconsider I said well I'm not
gonna reconsider it I had to have to
have a commitment a memo is worth
roughly what three pieces of paper are
worth which are blank and so I need to
get a commitment from the Provost for
the president that they would support
this which I got from Steve Hyman it was
the Provost then we topped two days
later and then I I drew the everlasting
enmity
of the Dean of the School of Public
Health at Hopkins for withdrawing my
acceptance it was only about five days
in there but in any event not something
I've ever done before and I saw I've
been at Harvard since and let me tie it
up with what I think is happening in
bioethics as I said much of it early on
was clinical stuff and to some degree
that's continued as more clinicians have
begun to work in the field of bioethics
you know they they are on ethics
committees they're running courses like
this that bob is and so it stayed
clinical then with the recognition of
how badly we were covering patients with
health insurance and with the Clinton
effort in the early 90s a lot more
attention to issues in the structure of
the healthcare system there was
beginning to be attention to a health
care costs then but more of the
attention then was to insurance coverage
and then of course the problems got
worse over the intervening almost two
decades and then when there was a
discussion of oh I guess you can be in
favor of it and still call it Obamacare
now I guess so when Obamacare came along
there was a lot of attention now given
to the structure of the health care
system and in particular how to fill
it's an easier problem and in a non
political sense but to know what to do
to deal with the problem of the 40-some
million that were without health
insurance it's a much harder problem
OOP
I guess this will still work without
that it's a much harder problem to know
how to control healthcare costs every
time the issue comes up people say
that's rationing that's dead death
panels etc etc and they want nothing to
do with it
the the effectiveness programs which are
a part of Obamacare evaluating different
interventions for a relative
effectiveness periodically someone would
say well you know maybe we should do
cost-effectiveness because really you
want to know what what differences in
cost there are between different
interventions not just differences in
effectiveness both of them would seem to
be what any rational person would want
to know when they were trying to figure
out what to cover what not to cover
what's been money on what not to spend
money on every time that came up in
Congress that was death panels that was
rationing and it never got through now
there are a variety of things and and
again this is something I commend to you
to learn about if you haven't but also
there going to be lots of experiments as
a result of the ACA Act
lots of experiments designed to try to
control costs most of them will be pilot
programs to see how well they work see
whether they can survive political
criticism and so forth but they're going
to be lots of things going on that will
be very interesting in the healthcare
system and if you want to work in
bioethics and in some ways it's a great
time to be doing it because there's
there are going to be big changes in the
structure of the healthcare system as he
command you all who I mentioned before
spent he's Rahm Emmanuel's brother so
that was a nice entree into some good
jobs in Washington
and seek worked in the office of
management budget on the healthcare
reform when Obama was putting it through
and he's now running the program at Penn
but there's just going to be if you're
interested in these policy questions a
lot of interesting things happening but
you have to you know bone up on what the
ACA is I don't know how many pages it is
but the one we put together for the
Clintons in 1993 was 1,400 pages it was
criticized for being way too long we and
some people say you should have just
quickly put out a 25 page thing and of
course what the criticism then would
have been this is one seventh of the
national economy and you're doing it
you're going to change it with 25 pages
so I think you were damned if you did
damned if you didn't in that case but
the ACA is very complicated with a lot
of interesting almost all of the ideas
for controlling health care costs that
health economists and others had are in
there and so it will be very interesting
to see how they play out they won't none
of them start basically yet the most
around - for 2014 and and some of them
later than that it would be very
interesting time because this is a
problem that is true throughout the
world I've been doing most of a lot of
my work recent years in global health
working with w-h-o and others and but
this problem of increasing skyrocketing
health care costs our problem is worse
than anybody else's we spend twice as
much per capita on health care as the
British do and their health statistics
are a little bit better than ours so
there's something wrong there but
so this is a worldwide problem but it's
it's very pressing here and so it'll be
interesting to see what works what
doesn't work when we try to control
costs the only other thing I'd like to
say and then open it up to discussion is
there's lots of interesting work being
done in global health these days and if
you have inclinations in that direction
I would urge you to pursue them Jeff
Sachs is here at Columbia who does a lot
of that my department chair at Harvard
is Paul Farmer who some of you have
probably heard of our department was
renamed global health and social
medicine a few years ago there is
increasing attention to issues of global
health we spend $8,000 per capita on
health care in this country there are
countries in Africa that spend around
$20.00 per capita on health care so you
can see the difference in the in nature
of the cost problem a lot of work coming
we've worked some a group of us at
Harvard have worked some with a World
Health Organization Dan wiggler is one
of my colleagues there was the first I
think probably oh the only but the first
staff philosopher there he was there for
two years about 10 years ago and we've
worked a lot with people doing
cost-effectiveness work at w-h-o and in
the country in some of the countries we
worked
whittler and I and a couple other people
worked with the Ministry of Health in in
Thailand which is a middle-income
country they spend a little over $100
per person on health and they wanted to
cover renal dialysis in their healthcare
program
it was covered in the to private
insurance plans in the country well they
couldn't afford to do so renal dialysis
unlike other life-sustaining treatments
it's not like you know you get the
person on the respirator I'm going to
spend the rest of their life there
they're gonna be off it and hopefully a
couple of weeks with renal dialysis
you're on it for the rest of your life
and so it's much it's more expensive
than a lot of other life-sustaining
interventions they want to cover it for
all the patients in need they could only
cover it afford to cover it for half the
patients in need so we had this
fascinating work with them over two
three years of how to decide who to
cover it for when you couldn't cover it
he they figured they had covered for
about half the the number of patients
who needed it so it was and needless to
say it's a sensitive issue so but there
are other examples like that coming up
all the time the World Health
Organization you know about the the 3x5
program which is a program at WH o which
is designed to get three million people
were HIV positive on antiretrovirals by
2005 well they didn't come close to
succeeding but when they set up the
program they estimated there were six
million patients who were in need of
that care and three million was the goal
all right what does that tell you that
tells you you better do some
prioritizing as to who you were going to
try to get on and they had some
interesting meetings that I was in some
of them at w-h-o trying to think about
WH other than do these programs what
they do is rules try to be a resource by
recommending to countries how to deal
with issues like this so one of the
examples was if you wanted to set up the
program to be cost effective to get as
many people as possible given the
resources that were available in the
countries on antiretrovirals what would
you do you would simply ignore
people in rural areas you would only
treat people in urban areas why because
they were in denser and so cheaper and
you already had more health facilities
in urban areas so the question was was
it fair to simply exclude the rural
patients or did they deserve some fair
chance at getting what they need these
kinds of issues come up all the time and
I find them interesting let me stop
there if I can start so contrary so if
you were someone coming out with a
masters like this answer I'd recommend
getting a PhD it depends on what other I
think a master's in bioethics if that's
your only professional degree beyond an
undergraduate degree for most people
it's not enough to be a sort of major
player in the debates
I used to encounter undergraduates at
Brown wanted to go on but in bioethics
and I wouldn't encounter often once had
been in philosophy majors are taking
philosophy courses because that's what I
was teaching there and I would tell them
to get into the best ph.d program they
could don't pay too much attention to at
that time the philosophy to programs
graduate programs that get ranked by
something that you don't need to know
about the Leiter report and Brown was
the highest ranked it was ranked about
usually 14 15 but it was the highest
ranked program that had anybody who was
doing principally applied ethics
it simply isn't the case that now this
has changed some but it isn't the case
that the best PhD programs in philosophy
are much interested in put in light
ethics Princeton now is some Harvard not
too much most of the best programs
aren't so I would tell them to get into
the best graduate program they could
where they could get trained in ethics
and political philosophy because a lot
of what you need now for these things
like thinking about the Affordable Care
Act and just distribution of health care
and so forth you need what gets called
political philosophy more than ethics
because what's relevant to the kind of
clinical issues is what I usually call
personal morality questions when it's
okay to lie and so forth so get into the
best graduate program you can get you
can do and without worrying too much
about how much bioethics you would do in
the ph.d program the best thing that we
did at Harvard unfortunately when Lehman
Brothers and everything else collapsed
we lost our funding but was a postdoc
program and training people in what we
usually call well we called it when I
could think of it no not see this is
what happened I was reassured by a
neurologist at one point is that the
part of the brain that remembers names
is not the part that is not the whole
memory so forgetting names does not mean
you're on the way to Alzheimer's but
well in any event it's we use the
metaphor of a bird's-eye view of health
of countries and health issues there are
certain things you can see from a
thirty-five thousand foot level
about health in a country or across
countries that you don't see at the
clinical level you see much better the
way social determinants are felt health
and health inequalities you see how
resources have been prioritized you see
a whole bunch of things that an
individual clinician tends not to see
when he's dealing patient by patient and
if I could only remember the name of
this the program that we set up was
looking at these issues that you see at
that level so they were issues around
the social determinants of health and
how they create social and health
inequalities they're issues about
prioritization of resources obviously
those are much more important globally
than they are in this country because
every everyone else spends so much less
than we do you see things like the way
environmental issues affect health most
of you are probably relatively affluent
and so you don't have to live it where
environmental problems are a real
problem others who are less affluent
often can't get away from those so
environmental risks are distributed
quite unequally and have big impacts on
health and so forth and so on
there issues about what what health
concerns should be the government's
responsibility or the state's
responsibility and what should be the
individuals responsibility there's a lot
of attention about individual behavior
in the way that affects health and Great
Britain that there was a survey done of
the population about two things whether
the National Health Service should fund
the removal of forget exactly what it
was but
stay peripheral stains that you're born
with and the removal of tattoos and the
public attitude was yes to the former no
to the latter and that was because of
views about responsibility for your
healthcare needs people who'd gotten
tattoos you know live with it that was
the attitude now right now Americans pay
out of pocket for about 40% of their
health care even with insurance so this
is who should be responsible for what is
still a big issue and of course globally
even more so health inequalities in fact
in in developing countries are usually
worse than here because the elites
corner the money often use it to go to
this country or other places so the
inequalities in some cases are even
worse there so there's a lot of interest
there's a lot of interest in these
issues certainly among the students at
Harvard and I imagine the students at
Columbia too and there's just a lot of
of interesting work to be done
that is you speak to the roots of
bioethics sources and stuff and it's
it's fundamentally clinical and we
concerns the president's commissioners
in the early hospital policies have to
do with issues and you're saying no and
when you put together a program clinical
ethics is sort of like a no-brainer this
is what you're gonna have 20 glasses and
you're saying you know way the direction
that these rooms have flowered into a
tree is populations so that's what we
call it actually so thank you for
reminding me they would call the
population level like my my feet are
planted in public health now and I work
I've done that because of some
relationship that relationship ethics of
public through population grew this is
hard but we know that how healthcare is
delivered is one-on-one and when you
step back they don't have any people in
them do they write the the you know the
the when I went to Harvard I was in
charge of two programs one was the
division of medical ethics which was in
the medical school my appointment it
wasn't is in the medical school the
division Medical Ethics was in the
medical school we were responsible we
now have record teaching for all medical
students a fair amount of curricular
time 15 week course two hours a week so
it's a reasonable amount of curricular
time and that's required for all
first-year students now and that's
mostly clinical because as you say
that's what bioethics particularly in
medical schools typically is what led me
to
reverse my decision to go to Hopkins and
instead go to Harvard
was the population level I'm thoroughly
indebted to you but was the program an
ethic we called it the program in ethics
and health so people wouldn't think of
it as just medical ethics with the
clinical stuff and that we turned out
some you know we have a postdoc program
we had about 70 applicants every year
for two slots we got our first choices
every year and we've sent people out
into good positions doing good work
tenure track jobs and lots of good at
universities but it's it's it's a whole
group of issues that have huge effects
on health much bigger than then medical
care a whole group of issues that are
ethically interesting because they're
all about health inequalities and what
health and he called is you can you
think are justified what's causing those
health inequalities what can you do to
reduce them if you think they should be
reduced what health inequalities are okk
are ethically unobjectionable it's a
whole group of issues that bioethicists
medical ethicists have not paid much
attention to and yet you know so we've
been trying to sell the importance of
them until Harvard lost ten billion
dollars in its endowment we were doing
just fine doing that and we're not doing
just fine right now in terms of the
support of the program but there is
increasing interest in it and there's
lots of interesting academically
interesting things to do there's a group
out of Washington state of Washington
the Institute for Health metrics and
evaluation run by Chris Murray Chris
Murray had been at at WH oh I won't give
you all the details but he left he came
back to Harvard here's the guy who was
head of well one of the billionaires in
computer pardon
no not Gates that's who I ended up with
well you can see I have a problem with
names an event promised Ellison Larry
Ellison the reason what maybe you think
of it as I have a letter with Ellison
Institute stationery on it now it never
had never got off the ground but Ellison
promised Chris 100 million dollars to
spend not not endowment so that's over
ten years and then when when summers got
pushed out as President Ellis backed out
Chris of course Mary is a guy who lands
on his feet he got 120 million from
gates and has gotten substantial
additional since then what they have
done is to redo what was called the
global burden of disease study it was
the joint study 1993 between the World
Bank and w-h-o it attempted to over the
entire world to measure the impact both
in longevity and in quality of life
health health related quality of life of
about 200 diseases in various regions of
the world nothing like this had ever
been done before and the data was a
little thin at that time what they have
been doing since is to redo that study
it's now been published if you're
interested in a recent issue of Lancet
the biggest issue they ever published is
entirely devoted to the
results of this study and it has big
impacts because it tells you what gates
loved and the reason he's funding it is
because you now got data and you can see
now what's needed where and you can
measure the impacts of various programs
there's a story in a you know piece on
gates in The New Yorker several years
ago where I think it was then that then
head of the Fogarty Center at NIH which
is the international study that sit
under there was with gates and gates
asked him for some stuff to read so he
he said gates about 80 books might as
well take advantage of the opportunity
and saw gates two three weeks later and
he's asked him how he was coming on
these really busy and he said well I
won't read 13 of them so far so he asked
him which he liked best and what he
liked best was the 1993 global burden of
disease study which is that it was a
book why because it told you what the
problem was it told you for example it
put the treatment of depression
worldwide much higher in priorities than
it had been before because a lot of the
value of valuation of health effects had
been mortality studies that's not the
main impact of depression and so it
changed the perception of the world on
relative health needs and health
priorities and that's what gate gates
loved and started giving money away so
Chris has a big Institute and if you're
interested if you're interested in some
of the epidemiological work and so forth
you know there are places like this
where you can spend time and do
fascinating work
get out there and do it any other yes
in addition together
how that will help
after the menses sensitive issue context
a lot of people that take masters you
know I don't know the details here but I
know the details at some other places I
know the details at Penn because I have
to know fair amount about that and I
imagine it's similar here a lot of the
people who do masters and to their
credit they get interested because
they're on an IRB like you are or
they're on an ethics committee every
hospital now has an ethics committee
when I first started this area no
hospital I don't know if X committee
literally so every hospital has an
ethics committee and ethics issues in
health care settings like hospitals you
know they're there they're dealt with
more explicitly than they used to be to
some degree there may be more issues but
I doubt that actually so you know I
don't know what a survey of the students
here it would show but I imagine a lot
of them are similar to you who they're
on IR B's they've gotten interested
through their practice one of my
colleagues Bob Krug got interested in
these issues
newly didn't know anything about ethics
he had never written a paper as an
undergraduate at UCLA and it was a real
pre-med guy and anyone I wrote a paper
and he went searching around for a
co-author so but then he did he did
study study more I think the if you want
to try to operate you know I consider
myself to be exceedingly fortunate
because I've had a vastly more
interesting career than I had any reason
to expect when I went and graduates ago
velocity I mean it really is several of
my colleagues and I have talked about
this and we we've been lucky but if you
want to do some of the things that I've
been talking about that I've found so
interesting you are more likely to be
able to the more sophisticated your
training is and inevitably it's not
going to be as sophisticated in a
master's program as it would be in a
ph.d program and you know I'm not saying
you should go to get a PhD in philosophy
especially good justice well be in
medical anthropology you know several of
my colleagues at Harvard have medical
anthropology degree is farmer Haslam Jim
Kim had one and so forth so but the kind
of studying questions at a level of
depth that you do in a ph.d program I
think enables you to do more
sophisticated work for example if you're
publishing a fair amount then and doing
a lot of research then a master's
program sort of prepares you for how you
say so a long I know I agree with you
but I think a lot of students a lot of
our students do a master's and then go
on and get a medical degree or a law
degree or go people for with the Masters
and bioethics then get a PhD because to
get a page you first need to get a
masters you don't go from college to a
deep go from college to a master's
program
some people decide they want to do a
master's in public health or master's in
public policy in the cetera yeah I think
so it's a master's this is a step toward
the PhD it's not an either/or it's one
and then the other one and it's also the
case that if you're also doing if you're
going to medical school
then I don't that will sort of play the
role of the PhD you will do slightly
different kinds of things but you'll be
lots of people probably most of the
people who are sort of active
bioethicists who publish and so forth
are probably Doc's so I wasn't trying to
push it came out wrong if your master's
in bioethics is your only training
beyond undergraduate work then I think
you're probably not going to be able to
work at as a sophisticated level as if
you have a law degree a medical degree a
public health degree whatever it's that
kind of training forces you to push
deeper anybody graduates high school
graduate
there's more physics in Galloway and me
mr. personal the most adaptive is at
times have changed a lot so in another
sense you know people who study from
study bioethics when when they leave
this program they know more about
bioethics than you knew when you left a
doctoral program at Columbia University
and when I I'm gonna I was in the same I
was in the same situation so you come
you come into the field so the problem
becomes able to earn an honor well you
end up you end up learning that part on
your own to practice that you're at the
roots of it so you develop so you points
that are in a really interesting issue
here that has to do with the new age in
in bioethics in which these folks are
not being trained that's population
ethics and somehow or other they gonna
have to get into that if they're gonna
do their work right so there are a
parallel situation it's a little
paradoxical but nevertheless something
very valuable to point out is that folks
will come out of out of this program
I'll have better preparation right that
at that moment of leaving the program if
you are Art Caplan or Dan Callahan won't
really all three of you guys but a lot
of it a lot about about Greek philosophy
and everything else but so far as the
nitty-gritty of bioethics you learn that
in practice and I think there's over you
got it head start on this that's it you
need also to to go beyond that just as
as we like Bianca
one other thing that's good if you want
a career in bioethics is if your your
name is Dan because they're actually
quite a few Dan's there's Dan wiggler
Dan Callahan Norman Daniels Dan brach
Dan Houseman and I could go on very
I got there in 1969 when the new
curriculum started let me say it again
there's
one of the other interesting things
about access is that I think my
generation deserves some credit and
because when I first started doing some
of this physicians were extremely
skeptical about people like me being
involved in these issues and we really
had to work hard to earn credibility
that was why I think it was very
important for me to have that
philosopher in residence in the hospital
experience where I spent half of a year
full-time in a clinical setting so it's
it's now you guys are expected right I
mean there were IR bees were just
beginning when I came into this field as
I mentioned before ethics committees
didn't exist at all any place and so it
was peculiar to have non clinicians
around in these settings and so I think
you're right a lot of it is access but I
think the access is a lot easier
nowadays because a lot of physicians now
come to recognize that other people may
have some contributions to make some of
the concerns they have in some ways may
help them and make their job easier so
it the access is this partly just power
and credentials but it's also a
recognition that this is an
interdisciplinary field and you can get
different contributions from different
kinds of people you know you wouldn't go
to I always tell people when at when
legal issues come up when I'm teaching
you'd be an idiot to take legal advice
from a philosopher but but lawyers who
work in these areas have a lot to
contribute and obviously the physicians
but and so forth so unfortunate out of
time but please join me and thank you